[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Greetings, everyone.
My name is Dan
Carpenter and I am
director of social
sciences academic ventures
at the Radcliffe Institute
for Advanced Study.
We are thrilled that today's
lecture is part of HUBweek,
which-- if you're not
familiar with it--
is an ambitious
civic collaboration
between The Boston Globe,
MIT, Mass General Hospital,
and Harvard that showcases
innovation and creativity.
The commitment to
ideas and discovery
that HUBweek celebrates
is at the core
of Radcliffe's dual mission--
first, to support innovative
research and creative
work that cuts
across disciplines;
and, second, to share
that work with the public
through a packed calendar
of events, such as this one.
I also want to extend
an acknowledgement
to the many reunion classes
who are here this week.
We are celebrating
several fall reunions.
And so a special
welcome to the members
of the classes of 1972,
1977, and 1987 who
are with us here today.
I'd like to highlight a few
of the upcoming events that
might be of particular
interest to you.
You can find complete details
on our calendar cards, which
are available at the back of
the room and at the registration
table downstairs, or
you can find them online
at Radcliffe.Harvard.edu.
First, each year Radcliffe
holds a major science symposium.
In the fall this year's
symposium, entitled Contagion--
Exploring Modern Epidemics,
will investigate new ways
to understand, track, and
respond to epidemic diseases,
as well as social epidemics.
That symposium will
take place here
in the Knafel Center
on Friday, October 27.
Next Monday, October 16, a
closely related lecture series
on epidemics will kick off
with a talk called Epidemiology
Counts, on causes, consequences,
and healthy populations--
by Boston University School
of Public Health Dean Sandro
Galea.
Dean Galea will
discuss the complexity
of how we measure the
health of the population
and how we determine
which of the factors
influencing health
matters the most.
And finally, we
are looking forward
to welcoming historian Michael
Kazin, a distinguished scholar
of American politics
and social movements
and editor of the
magazine Dissent.
He will give a lecture entitled
"Does the Left Have a Future"
here in the Knafel Center
on Thursday, November 2.
I hope you will be
able to join us.
Finally, let me invite
you all to a reception
to continue the conversation
following this talk immediately
after the Q&A session
this afternoon.
The reception will take
place right next door
on the first floor
of Agassiz House.
After the talk
from Julie Guthman
there will be a question
and answer session,
at which there will be
a standing mic placed
in the center the center aisle.
Please identify
yourself, form a line,
identify yourself before
you ask a question.
And now let me introduce
today's speaker.
Julie Guthman is a
professor of social sciences
at the University of California,
Santa Cruz, and the Frances B.
Cashin Fellow here at Radcliffe
her research has focused
on how neoliberal inflected
capitalism shapes possibilities
for food system transformation.
As a Radcliffe Fellow,
Guthman is writing a book
that traces how the soil
pathogen Verticillium dahliae
gave rise to the technologies
and institutions that
brought the California
strawberry industry success,
yet at the same time locked
in a system of production that
renders less intensive
methods nearly unviable.
Today Guthman will discuss
the origins and development
of the alternative
food movement and how
it came to focus on
market-based alternatives
as well as how the movement
has evolved in response
to critiques-- for instance
that it has done little
to undermine industrially
produced food
and has struggled to
resonate with poor people
and communities of color.
Guthman holds a PhD in
geography from the University
of California Berkeley.
She has won four different books
awards, including the Frederick
H. Buttel Outstanding
Scholarly Achievement
Award from the Rural
Sociological Society
for her book Agrarian Dreams--
The Paradox of Organic
Farming in California,
as well as the ASFS Book
Award for Weighing In--
Obesity, Food Justice, and
the Limits of Capitalism.
She is also a recipient
of the Agriculture, Food,
and Human Values
Society's Excellence
in Scholarship Award
and her research
has received funding from the
National Science Foundation,
as well as being herself
a resident fellow
of the Rockefeller
Foundation Bellagio Center
and the University of California
Humanities Research Institute.
I'll also add she is the
2017 Guggenheim Fellow.
Finally, let me underscore, as
a way of thanking our friends
and supporters at
Radcliffe, that Julie
is this year the
Frances B. Cashin
Fellow and her
fellowship is generously
supported by Richard M. Cashin
and Elizabeth S. Cashin--
class of '75, both.
And finally, a personal note--
I had a wonderful and enjoyable
dinner conversation with Julie
last night.
And I learned a lot about her
work, her family, her food
habits--
which are far more
tasteful than mine.
We discussed many
issues in the news
which have been
rather depressing
and which I won't
alight upon here,
but I found her
insights at every stage
to be profoundly thoughtful
and creatively expressed.
I am honored and excited to
have a new colleague in Julie
and I ask you to extend
her a warm welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
- Well, hi there.
And thank you, Dan, for that
really kind introduction.
I appreciate it.
And I really thank all
of you for coming today.
It is truly an honor
and a privilege
to be here at the
Radcliffe Institute.
And I am deeply grateful to the
work of Dean Cohen, Associate
Dean Vichniac, and their
truly superlative staff
in keeping things ticking.
And I'm especially
honored to be invited
to speak here during Boston
HUBweek and Harvard Reunion
Week.
That's all to the good.
Now, the bad news is I
came down with a cold
and so you will have to excuse
my particularly gravelly voice
today and literal
throat clearing.
And now for the figurative
throat clearing of my talk.
So I want to begin with
the 2014 New York Times
column penned by noted
food writer Mark Bittman.
In this column,
Bittman described
having a negative visceral
reaction to the word "foodie."
Foodies, he argued, are too
often new style epicures
who enjoy watching
competitive cooking shows,
doing anything to get a table
at the trendy restaurant,
scouring the web for
single estate farro--
I've not done that one--
or devoting oneself to
finding the best food truck.
If and when these foodies go
beyond the pursuit of pleasure,
he noted they tend to put their
energies into consumer support
for sustainable food systems--
such as the purchase of
organic and local foods,
participating in
community-supported agriculture
projects, or buying
at farmers' markets.
This, he suggested,
was not quite enough.
He went on to say that making
good food fair and affordable
cannot be achieved without
going beyond food to address
questions of justice
and equality and rights,
of enhancing rather than
restricting democracy;
of making a more rational,
legitimate economy.
Now, as it happens,
Bittman's column
borrowed a critique that
I and other scholars,
in conversation with
activists, have been
making for a very long time.
We have argued that
many foodies' and food
activists' focus on consumption
has overemphasize relatively
apolitical market based
strategies such as patronizing
and creating alternative
food businesses.
We have pointed out that
these strategies have
been embraced and promoted
by those who are generally
well-off and white.
We have suggested that attempts
by foodies and food activists
to shift the public's eating
habits toward the notions
of good food have too
often been encased
in a politics of conversion.
The attempts to change
individual eating habits
without understanding the
multiple circumstances,
pressures, and desires
that inform food choices.
It's a classic missionary
position, if you will.
And we've claimed
that food activism,
in focusing on
consuming good food,
has taken the focus off the
conditions of food production,
particularly neglecting
the needs of those
who work in the food system.
Indeed, as building
positive alternatives
has become the nearly sole
activity of the food movement,
food producers and
processors have
been effectively
let off the hook
for their harmful practices.
Little, that is, been done to
undermine the conventional food
system.
Now, in making
these critiques we
have both angered and
inspired food activists.
Some have suggested that these
critiques are disempowering.
Some have said they've
known them all along
and didn't feel they
could voice them.
And some have been motivated
to rethink what they do.
So today I want to
do three things aside
from shameless promotion
for my new co-edited book.
I want to talk about the origins
and development of the food
movement as a way to
explain how it became
about market-based
alternatives, often
at the expense of
social justice.
Secondly, I want to show how it
evolved in response to critique
such as ours.
And on that note,
I want to suggest
that these critiques have been
generative and not necessarily
disempowering.
And they have led to more
inclusion, or attempts
at inclusion, of social
justice concerns.
And then I want
to briefly discuss
three cases that reflect this
new food activism, one of which
focuses on a battle that
motivated my current research
and led to my project
here at Radcliffe.
Alas, I won't be discussing
my Radcliffe project today,
but I would be delighted to
answer questions about it
at the end.
And I will then
conclude by talking
about the challenges
and opportunities
of the current moment.
And it is a challenging
current moment.
First, I want to
be clear on what
food movement I'm referring to.
After all, various
forms of food activism
have been around for
a very long time.
So I want to discuss
what many refer to
as the "alternative
food movement."
And I begin with the
organic farming movement
because it was so
clearly a progenitor
of this market-based approach
to food system transformation.
Now, in this slide, the person
on the left is unknown to me,
but the person on the
right is Alan Chadwick.
Chadwick came to my university--
University of
California Santa Cruz--
in 1967 and began the famed UCSC
organic Farm and Garden, which
now has created-- many, many
farmers around the world
once worked or trained
at the UCSC Farm.
And his approach was based
on the French Intensive
biodynamic gardening.
Now, there's legend
that he and the students
used to farm naked.
I'm fairly willing
to believe it.
And I do know that there's a
few UCSC alums in the audience
today, and I'd bet that
they would probably
believe it as well.
But I actually want to start
my story a few years later,
and that's in 1973.
And I use 1973 as a
watershed because that's
when a group of
farmers, primarily
from California and Oregon--
and here I'm talking
about the US, of course--
here's when they began
codifying organic agriculture.
In so doing, they
developed a novel way
to regulate agriculture, without
the support of the government.
In the minds of many
organic farmers at the time
the US Department of
Agriculture and all
the other regulatory
agencies that
might be involved in
agriculture had utterly
failed to support
an agriculture that
would conserve soils and reduce
the use of toxic chemicals.
So the original organic
farmers opted instead
to share the techniques
they had learned
and call what they did
"organically grown."
Now, there's longer
origins of organic farming
that I'm not going
to go into today.
But at this point, their goal
was to give organic farming
meaning in the marketplace.
So as the organic name
began to have cache,
organic farmers
needed to find a way
to guarantee to consumers that
their purchases were indeed
organically grown.
And every once in a while there
would be some sort of public
scare over the incorrect
or excessive use
of a pesticide and consumers
would clamor for organics.
And so many producers
would respond
by becoming organic overnight--
in other words, by faking it,
claiming that they were organic.
And, understandably,
the real organic farmers
didn't like that.
So they wanted to come up with
a system in which they would
decide what would
be called organic
and make sure that these newly
arrived organic farmers follow
the rules.
And so these farmers
wanted to come up
with a set of what inputs and
practices would be allowable
in an organic system.
Now, at first these were
just organic inspectors.
At first the rules they
developed were very simple.
Legend goes that
they were written
on a half a page of paper.
But the guiding
principles they used
were generally about that
whether the materials that
would be allowed
on an organic farm
were natural and
not synthetic Now,
that turned out to be a
highly contentious distinction
but that's a discussion
for another day--
or I am happy to
answer questions
about the organic
rules during the Q&A.
But these guys also figured
out it wasn't enough just
to set standards.
It wasn't enough to decide which
materials would be allowable
in organic production systems.
They had to find a way
to guarantee that growers
would follow the rules.
So they came up with a
system of peer review--
is existing organic farmers
would inspect new farms
to see if these new farmers
were farming in keeping
with these organic principles.
If they decided that they were,
these peer review inspectors
would certify the
farms as organic.
Again, another legend--
or not so much a legend,
this is came down with many
interviews I conducted years
ago--
at first certification
was based on a system of,
you know it when you see it.
Today, organic certification
is much, much more complex.
There are Baroque review
processes for the materials
alone--
and there's hundreds
and hundreds,
thousands of materials that
are reviewed every year to see
if they would meet the basic
distinction of natural,
not synthetic, not toxic.
And now, you know,
there's huge volumes
that now contain the list
of allowable materials
or disallowed materials.
Today there are hundreds of
certification agencies run
by states, non-government
organizations,
and private businesses as well.
And these guys all
certify farmers.
And in the United
States this is all
overseen by the
federal government--
although the federal
government itself is not
in the business of actually
certifying farmers.
Now, there's a lot more
to say about organic rules
and certification and
whether they work effectively
to ensure the integrity
of organic practices.
But the point I
want to make today
is actually quite different.
Because regardless of the
complications involved,
this was a system
that, in it's essence,
was supposed to
reward good behavior.
Producers that wanted to
enter the organic sector
would agree to abide
by a set of rules
and pay the cost
of certification.
And in doing so they
expected to be rewarded,
and they expected to be
rewarded with a price
premium for their efforts.
Now, this system made
sense at the time.
I don't think these
growers went out
to come up with a system
that wouldn't work.
I think they just
kind of-- its evolved.
But it turns out the
approach had its drawbacks--
and drawbacks that really didn't
become evident until organics
entered the mainstream.
So one consequence
of this approach
is that it allowed
significant co-optation.
Organic farmers were
fetching very high prices
for their produce for a while,
particularly in the 1980s.
But as the organic
sector grew, some farmers
began to lose out on
the price premiums
due to intense competition
as many new entrants came
about-- including companies
like Walmart would
bring new organic farmers in.
They often would work
with conventional farmers,
convince them to grow
organically for them--
because they actually thought
that these conventional farmers
knew how to grow better than
the original organic farmers
and would be more reliable.
So what happened is that farmers
that wanted to take advantage
of the high prices or that
were asked to grow organically
on behest of the WalMarts or
the Whole Foods or whatever--
you know, the Mountain
People's Warehouse,
that was a distributor--
those guys all asked
growers to grow organically.
And so these
farmers came into it
based on that kind
of market demand,
but they weren't
committed to incorporating
the agroecological principles.
And so what they
would do is kind
of substitute allowable organic
inputs for disallowed ones.
So they'd enter if there was
an input that you could easily
substitute.
And that means that
there was more entry
in some crops than others.
So the point here is
that they didn't really
fully embrace the integrated
systems that organic farming
was founded on.
Now, the original organic
farmers, understandably,
didn't like this--
nor did others who
had hoped for more,
who had hoped that organic
would mean everything that
was different, they
wanted to be completely
different than the
conventional food system.
So growers in the
Northeast, for example,
were unhappy to see organic
produce shipped from California
in their markets.
And I myself was surprised
shopping at the Whole Foods
at Fresh Pond to
see organic kale
from California in September.
I mean, if you can't grow
organic kale in Massachusetts
in September, I don't know.
And it wasn't very good
shipped, I have to tell you.
So as organic stopped being
effective in supporting
the small farmers that
birthed the movement,
it gave rise to many
beyond organic ideas--
including locally
grown, including
fair trade, and many others.
Now, these new
labels were in part
to address the social issues
that the organic standard had
pretty much neglected.
They were also designed
to support higher prices
for farmers, with
the expectation
that these high prices would
enable growers to incorporate
ecological principles--
or perhaps pay workers
better or otherwise just
stay in business.
But the thing about
these standards
is they serve as
barriers to entry.
They are purposefully
difficult to meet
to ensure the integrity
of each of these labels.
And they're difficult to prevent
that quick and easy entry
that those organic
farmers once saw.
But this became a major
point of contention
for the organic
movement or industry.
On the one hand, high
standards are good.
They can ensure that a labeled
food is truly different.
On the other hand,
high standards
can work against
broader transformation
by keeping producers out.
And this is what the
conventional growers moving
into organics would
always sell to me.
They told us they wanted to
feed the world with organics.
Why are they making
it hard for us?
And the fact is they did
make it hard for them.
Because despite
all the attention
that's given to organics,
all the talk about it,
and that it putatively
grows 20% per year, only 1%
of US farmland is currently
in organic production.
Which is a stunningly
low figure.
Furthermore, by
rewarding only producers
who use good practices,
those with the bad practices
remained unconscionably
under-regulated.
Conventional
producers could still
use highly toxic
materials and inputs,
and this food would
necessarily be cheaper--
which also means that
the system of regulation
put the cost burden on the
good practices for consumers.
Those consumers who
value the qualities
here in these labels--
and if they valued them, they'd
have to pay more for them.
So organic and its
cognates, in other words,
became more costly by design.
So that necessarily created
a problem of affordability.
And so that led to some new
social movement attempts.
One of the first, after this
kind of organic and local,
was community food security.
The community food
security movement
emphasized that both
growers and consumers
would do better economically if
they cut out the middle person.
So it put a great
deal of emphasis
on direct marketing
arrangements.
Farmers markets, community
supported agriculture,
were supposedly both consumers
and producers would benefit--
although certainly
not the workers
who work in
distribution companies.
In practice, though,
that particular win-win
didn't happen.
So some markets were
organized to ensure
high prices for farmers by
price fixing or limiting
who would participate
in that market.
Now, the market pictured
here is Ferry Plaza
in San Francisco, renowned
for its beautiful but crazily
expensive produce.
Now, there are a lot of
farmers markets have sprung up
that were not so restricted.
And they do provide cheaper
produce for consumers,
but the farmers at these
markets wouldn't do as well.
And I've talked to
many farmers who
would refuse to sell at
the markets that weren't
the high end markets
because they knew
they couldn't get good prices.
There were additional issues.
Scholars and activists recognize
that nutritious food, defined
in less rarefied terms
then local and organic,
was lacking in many
urban environments--
particularly African-American
neighborhoods.
So this was creating a
problem of geographic as well
as economic access.
So lack of access
became a watchword
of the alternative
food movement.
And so here you
see some interface
with the food desert analysis
that much Michelle Obama
helped popularize.
An additional critique emerged
that upscale alternative food
was not resonating in
communities of color.
In other words, that
it borrowed too heavily
on whitened cultural
histories and practices.
Like, the thing that my
students loved to say
is like, I want to put
my hands in the soil--
when we know that
for, some people,
putting their hands
in the soil is not
a memory that's a good one.
So the food justice movement was
born out of these observations.
Borrowing from environmental
justice activism,
food justice activists made
two different critiques.
One is that they noted
that people of color
were disproportionately
exposed to junk food
based on the lack of economic
and geographic access;
and, two, they noted that
the food movement primarily
appealed to the
white and privileged.
To address the access problem,
food justice organizations
set up shop in
neighborhoods of color.
For instance, they ask liquor
stores to feature fresh fruits
and vegetables.
They developed produce
delivery services
from nearby organic farms.
And they set up farmers
markets in some food deserts.
To address the
cultural issue, they
tried to bring foods
that were associated
with African-American food
ways, such as collard greens
and melons.
And I am particularly
focusing on African-American
neighborhoods here because they
have gotten the lion's share
of focus from food activism.
The activists also tried to
encourage people of color
to participate and
take leadership
in these organizations.
Now, the results
of these efforts
were honestly quite mixed.
And many residents in the
so-called "food deserts" voice
that they really just
wanted a supermarket
in their neighborhood.
Following that trend,
the food movement
turned to urban farms
and community gardens.
The idea here was to further
close the gap between producer
and consumer.
And the urban
agriculture movement
also aspire to create
community and provide a safety
net when public
entitlements are lacking.
And research suggests
that the farms that
have taken hold, the urban
farms that have taken hold, best
are in communities
with residents
not eligible for public
food assistance--
such as among recent immigrants,
particularly undocumented
recent immigrants.
And most recently
food justice activists
began to borrow from peasant
movements in the developing
world and have called
for "food sovereignty--"
community control
of the food system.
And then, even more
recently, borrowed
on things like the
Occupy Movement
to do the Occupy
the Farm movement.
Now, I'll just briefly
elaborate here.
This is a event that took
place in Berkeley, California--
where I do happen to live.
And this is University property.
It's the Gill
Tract, and it's been
used as an agricultural
experimentation for years.
And activists took it over
so as an Occupy the Farm
and wanted to prevent the
university from selling it
to a land developer who was
going to develop a Sprout
supermarket there-- like a
Whole Foods type supermarket--
and a senior recreation center.
Just as an aside, this
was the kind of thing
that really frustrated
me because it seemed
to me that what would
have been a really more
important strategy
was for them to demand
that the University
of California
change the kind of research
it's doing at the Gill Tract
to support more
sustainable methods--
but they wanted to occupy.
Now, let me pause to say
that there's a lot that
is exciting about all this.
Clearly, food activism has
galvanized young people
in a big way.
There are more food
initiatives in more cities
than we could have possibly
imagined 25 years ago.
Funders are paying
attention and nonprofits
are growing like weeds.
And judging by my
students, young people
are increasingly aware of and
concerned about the injustices
of industrial food production.
And let's face it, there's
a lot more good food
and I, for one,
really like good food.
Yet there are still some serious
limits to these approaches.
One is that they
continue to emphasize
the consumption of food even
though some of the worst
injustices stem from
the production of food.
Now, note that over
20 million people
work in the food sector
in the United States,
providing about one
sixth of employment.
But people who work in food are
some of the most food insecure
because of the poor wages
in food processing, food
service, and farm work.
And it's not only the pay--
food workers face really
dangerous working conditions--
particularly in meat packing--
and sexual harassment.
Farm workers face the
worst pesticide exposures,
because many chemicals
are formulated
with consumer health in mind.
And, of course, many
food and farm workers
have very little means to
contest these conditions
because they're undocumented.
So basically you
have an approach
to changing the food system
that ignores the workforce
in the food system,
Another limit to
this approach is
that it promotes alternatives
rather than contest
what's wrong.
So in effect we're getting
a bifurcated food system--
we get great food for the
well-endowed, well located,
and well-funded, and
dregs for the rest,
including those who
work in the food system.
Now, when I've given
talks like this,
people say, but you have
to have alternatives.
And you do have to
have alternatives.
You have to have
alternatives and opposition.
If you oppose industrial
agricultural's practices,
you need to develop
and disseminate
safer and less toxic
ways of producing food.
And indeed growers are
much more willing to move
to more sustainable
methods when there
are viable agronomic
tools to help them.
But with some very
small exceptions,
the contemporary food movement
has focused almost solely
on building alternatives.
At the same time that community
gardens and direct marketing
and farming and cooking
education programs
have proliferated, work on
policy and corporate behavior
has pretty much dwindled.
But that, just
recently, is changing.
And in my remaining
time I'm going
to focus on three examples
that respond directly
to these critiques.
And all these examples are
drawn from the new book,
and so I'm drawing on
other people's research
besides my own.
So I'm going to begin
here with an alternative,
but an alternative that is
organized by people of color
and sees action as collective
rather than individual.
And here I'm drawing
from research
by [? Alison ?]
[INAUDIBLE] and [INAUDIBLE]
So this is about Chicago's
Healthy Food Hub,
and it was established
in 2009 with the aim
of pooling the
resources of its members
and surrounding communities
to bring home healthier,
tastier, fresher food for less.
This is mainly achieved
through collective purchasing
of wholesale organic
produce-- so it's
back to the old
collective purchasing
model of the 1970s that
so thrived in Cambridge,
Massachusetts when
I visited here then.
And they also buy
directly from rural farms
in the historic black
farming community
of Pembroke Township, Illinois.
This is a membership
organization.
People pay an annual fee
of $25 to become a member,
and then they receive
discounts on food products
and can preorder their food.
Now, what's significant here
is that the Healthy Food
Hub was not initially conceived
as a food justice initiative.
It began spontaneously
among a group of patient
in the care of
the Hub's founder,
an African-American
holistic practitioner based
in south Chicago.
She noted that many of
her patients' conditions
stemmed from poor
nutrition, so she
expanded what was then her
household practice of buying
food in bulk to include her
patients and their families,
in order to secure the best
quality food for the best
available prices.
Critically, the strategy
of a collective buying club
has deep historical roots in
longstanding African-American
practices of collective
survival and resistance.
For instance, the Populist
Colored Farmers' Alliance
organized purchasing
cooperatives to,
quote, "Resist the power
of white creditors,"
unquote, during Reconstruction.
The founders of the Healthy
Food Hub, as well as
many of its older
members, came to Chicago
with their respective
families from Mississippi
during the 1950s and '60s.
And many remember
collective food purchasing
as a routine family practice.
So this shared
cultural memory may
be one reason why the Hub has
been so successful at enrolling
and engaging its members
while other alternative food
organizations, working
in similar communities,
have really struggled.
Now I'm going to turn to one
of several campaigns connected
to the Food Chain
Workers Alliance,
which is a coalition of
worker-based organizations
who are organizing
to improve wages
and working conditions for
workers along the entire food
chain.
And this case study comes from
Joanne Low and [INAUDIBLE] Now,
this campaign took
place at Taylor Farms,
which is based in
California's Central Valley.
And Taylor Farms is one of
the world's largest processors
of salads and fresh
cut produce, selling
to retailers such as WalMart,
Trader Joe's, and Krogers.
They also sell to Chipotle.
But because of the
anonymity provided
by private labels and
institutional buyers,
Taylor Farms is
also a company that
exists beyond the influence
and even knowledge of most
individual consumers.
Now, about 900 people--
mostly Latino--
were working at two different
plants in California's Central
Valley.
2/3 of these workers
were employed
through temporary
staffing agencies,
even though some
of them had been
working at Taylor Farms for
many years-- over a decade.
Most were paid the minimum wage.
And, on average, the
workers in these plants
were earning $3 less per hour
then their similar workers
doing the same job in
the Salinas operations
of Taylor Farms, which tends
to be higher wages in Salinas.
And beyond the
notoriously poor wages.
The company accrued $80,000
an occupational safety
and health violations
from 2008 to 2013.
So in 2013, after months of
behind-the-scenes organizing,
workers at the Taylor Farms
plants in Tracy, California--
that's in the Central Valley--
announced they were
organizing to join a union.
Taylor Farms responded with a
variety of anti-union tactics.
On the stick side these included
intimidation, harassment,
and mistreatment.
For instance, they threatened
to call [SPANISH]----
immigration-- and referred to
workers as Latinos [SPANISH]----
piece of shit Latinos--
and they fired their
union supporters.
On the carrot side, Taylor Farms
made some nominal improvements
to working conditions, such
as providing sick days.
Most notably and
gratuitously the company
gave roses to the
women on Mother's Day
and gave backpacks, jackets,
and scarves of the men
on Father's Day.
Despite the company's
anti-union tactics,
the worker leaders and
the Teamsters organizers
were able to collect
enough signatures on union
authorization cards to
file for an election
through the National
Labor Relations Board.
However, the process became
bogged down and didn't go far.
So the campaign turned
toward another strategy,
utilizing a model embodied
in the Good Food Purchasing
Policy adopted by the
city of Los Angeles.
The Good Food Purchasing Policy
sets purchasing guidelines
across five key values--
local food economies,
environmental sustainability,
humane animal treatment,
healthy nutrition standards,
and fair treatment
and compensation
of food chain workers.
The idea here was to
leverage purchasing power
of institutional buyers rather
than through individual fork
voting--
you've all heard of
voting with your fork?
The Teamsters went to the
Oakland Unified School Board
to inform them on what was
going on at Taylor Farms.
And at that meeting the
Oakland Unified School Board
announced that the school
district would no longer
be buying from Taylor Farms.
And this was a loss
of a huge contract.
Eventually they won a
settlement and fired
workers received back pay.
This last example is
based on my own research,
and concerns thwarting the
highly toxic chemical methyl
iodide.
Methyl iodine was
developed and released
to be an alternative
to methyl bromide.
Methyl bromide is an
ozone depleting substance
that has been the primary
armament of the California's
strawberry industry's
war with soil disease.
In the early 2000s, facing the
mandated phase-out of methyl
bromide, the strawberry industry
began looking for a replacement
chemical.
So University of
California researchers
developed the
compound methyl iodide
that was very structurally
similar to methyl bromide
but lacked the ability to
reach the upper atmosphere.
And so then they sold the
patent of methyl iodide
to Arysta LifeSciences
Corporation.
So Arysta first sought
federal approval
for the use of methyl iodide
on strawberries in 2002
but faced some problems.
Methyl iodide is apparently much
more toxic than methyl bromide.
It is a known neurotoxin
and carcinogen.
It's associated with
thyroid dysfunction,
respiratory illness,
lung tumors,
and it's a probable cause of
miscarriages and birth defects.
It's even used to induce
cancer in laboratory rats.
Now, I want to
emphasize something
about these chemical fumigations
that really have motivated
my existing research--
they are used before planting.
They're put in the
ground to get--
they're fumigated,
they're gases.
They're put in the ground to get
rid of soil disease and weeds.
They leave no residues on
plants, on strawberries.
So the people who are most
exposed to their toxicity
are those who live or work
near strawberry fields, who
don't have the option of
buying their way out--
by buying that organic
strawberry, for instance.
Now, early on in this
battle, over 50 scientists--
several of them Nobel
laureates in chemistry--
wrote a letter encouraging the
US Environmental Protection
Agency to deny registration.
After some stalling,
the EPA eventually
allowed the use
of methane iodide.
But methyl iodide faced
a much tougher fight
in California, which
has more stringent
environmental regulations.
There, activists organizations--
including anti-pesticide,
environmental, public health,
and farm worker groups--
went beyond fork voting and
mounted a major campaign
to prevent the chemical
from being registered.
The campaign concluded over
53,000 written public comments
collected, with almost all
but a handful objecting
to the use of the chemical.
It included media events,
it included public hearings,
publicizing the chemical's harm.
It included picketing
besides farmer's fields--
although not a lot of that.
In addition, activists
filed a lawsuit
against California's
pesticide regulatory agency
for failing to abide
by environmental law
and registering the chemical.
Long story short-- and
it is a long story--
the chemical was pulled
from commercial use
because Arysta no longer felt
it was economically viable.
And this is in large
part because growers
didn't adopt the chemical
for fear of public backlash.
This was an
unprecedented victory,
one of the few toxic
chemicals to be taken off
the market in the modern history
of US environmental regulation.
And since then the
strawberry industry
has become much more
serious about finding
non-chemical alternatives
to fumigation
than it had previously.
Unfortunately, as I'm writing
about my current book,
it's just not finding
an alternative
that's going to do it--
but that's another story.
So what do these
campaigns tell us?
They tell us it is possible
to work in collectives.
It is possible to organize.
It is possible to
be oppositional.
It's possible to win.
It's possible to have
people of color lead.
And it's possible to use
strategies other than voting
with your fork.
It's possible to be political.
So I want to end by
talking a little bit more
about the politics of the
possible in the age of Trump.
Now, many of the
arguments and critiques
I've developed over the
years about food movements
have come in conversation
with my students.
So for the last
14 years I've been
teaching in a program whose core
is a six month full-time field
study with a social justice
and social change organization.
This is a community
studies program.
And I've been the
faculty member who
works most closely with
students interested
in food and agriculture.
So I've been able
to closely track
what kinds of social change
opportunities are available
and what kind my projects are--
excuse me, what kind of projects
my students are interested in.
Many of my students,
to my chagrin,
have ended up in
projects where the aim is
to teach low income people
of color what to eat
or how to grow food.
That's all that they
can think of doing.
This is what
organizations are doing.
When I've pressed them
on these inclinations
and asked why they're not more
interested in public action,
I've heard many times over
that to focus on alternatives
is easier and more fun.
And even though they
are well trained
in the political
economy the food system,
they have also said that
affecting policy or changing
corporate behavior
seems impossible.
But that was before
Occupy Wall Street
and and Black Lives Matter,
two movements that have changed
the public conversation.
It was the Occupy
Movement that brought
inequality and the wealth gap
back into public discourse.
Without Black Lives
Matter we wouldn't
have many people,
including white people,
talking about how
color-blind activism works
too reenscribe white privilege.
These recognizable changes
in the public conversation
are no doubt the very things
to which the alt-right movement
is reacting.
Now, I don't think it's a
coincidence that these two
movements correspond closely
to the critiques of the food
movement I've discussed
earlier in my talk.
That the movement appealed
too much to markets
and profit-making as a
way to solve problems,
that it's too white, and
therefore these conversations
have provided new opportunities
for food movements to address
some of the underlying
causes of food inequities--
income and health inequality,
insufficient health and safety
regulation, immigration
policy, regressive taxes--
and to show how
these are connected.
Hate to put this next slide
up, but there you have it.
And this new-- you could tell
me when to just shift to another
slide so you don't
have to look at it--
this new food activism
couldn't be more
urgent in the age of Trump.
Should I go back?
You've had enough?
I have.
OK.
We're already witnessing
some of the attacks
on environmental regulation,
including pesticide regulation.
The US pesticide regulatory
system is far, far,
far from perfect, but it
has played a modest role
in preventing toxic exposures to
consumers, workers, and others.
But Scott Pruitt's EPA
suggests huge reversals.
Since being appointed he is
set to dismantle the agency's
pesticide research apparatus.
He's already reversed
a ban on chlorpyrifos,
a brain-harming agro-chemical
that was about to be enacted--
the ban, not the chemical.
Trump's immigration policies
need no introduction,
but building a wall
with the southern border
and ramping up the
deportations that
were well underway during
the Obama presidency
has not only worsened a labor
shortage that concerns growers,
it has caused the millions
of undocumented food and farm
workers in the United States
to live in constant fear,
unable to contest wage
theft, pesticide use
violations, and sexual
harassment and assault that
are mainstays of US
food and farm work.
According to some sources,
Trump is threatening
to cut more than $190
billion over 10 years
from food assistance programs--
programs that are already
insufficient and ensuring
that the country's
poor do not go hungry.
He's also threatening
to cut crop insurance
and other programs
that protect farmers,
although these are far
more controversial.
And he is packing
his administration--
to the extent that he's actually
packing his administration--
with those who seek no reins on
corporate behavior or mergers,
clearing the way for even more
corporate control of the food
system.
It's simply not clear to
me how individual choices
to purchase organic local
food at the farmer's market
will stop this agenda.
I just have to tell
this little story.
I think I have time.
The day after the election,
when I and many others
were nursing our sometimes
real and definitely proverbial
hangovers, I managed
to get out of the house
and go to the UCSC Library--
I don't know why
I went up there.
But there, in front
of the library,
was someone petitioning--
or he wasn't petitioning.
He had a clipboard and he was
signing up people for his farm,
to buy subscriptions to
get food from his farm.
It was a classic
community-supported
agriculture.
He was this typical Santa
Cruz blond, dreadlocks,
sandal-wearing guy.
And this was the day
after the Trump election.
And, I mean, to me this so
much captured the frustration
I have with the
alternative food movement.
It felt just so
irrelevant at that moment.
But the good news,
as we have seen,
is that the public is
onto the Trump agenda.
And we've seen a lot of
resistance and pushback
in many different
arenas, including those
that bear on our food system.
And at this point
I don't think we
have a choice but to
continue on in this vein.
So that's what I have to say.
I think you and I welcome
your questions and comments.
[APPLAUSE]
- Thank you.
[INAUDIBLE] much
more complex than I
thought it was going to be.
In my experience, corporations
are willing to change.
John Mackey once was
at MIT of Whole Foods,
his students are giving him the
proper real hard time saying,
why are you so expensive?
The poor can't afford it.
And his response was,
if they eat my food,
they won't fall as sick.
So in the long
run, they eat and I
failed to convince them, though,
to not eat pork ribs and Coke
and eat my food, so
I admit that failure,
but I'm open to any
way you can suggest.
And nobody really
had a suggestion.
When Doug [INAUDIBLE]
of Whole Foods--
of Trader Joe's came, he has
started something here called,
I think, Daily Table.
So he said, OK, how do I go
to a disadvantage [INAUDIBLE]
bring the costs down?
So he takes oranges and
all that are seconds--
we all like perfect oranges,
so if its got a blemish on it
you can buy it cheaper.
But the jury's still out on it.
Its a nonprofit.
Its soaked up a lot of money.
[INAUDIBLE] ultimately every
corporation I talked to says,
I cannot convince the Americans
to ask for price first--
the cheapest banana, the
cheapest chicken-- so
what do you want me to
do as a corporation?
You have an answer to that?
- Well, there's a few
things I want to say.
First of all, I do want
to say that corporations
are paying attention to
sustainability issues
as well-- oh, sorry.
Corporations are paying
attention to sustainability
issues as well.
I have a friend here--
she's visiting here
at Harvard this year--
who's working on corporate
sustainability initiatives.
But they are dragged
kicking and screaming.
I mean, they're not doing
that out of the goodness
of their hearts.
I mean, John
Mackey, when I first
doing my research
on organics 20,
25 years ago, he was
quoted as saying,
since when is this movement
about social justice?
But even though
corporations are maybe
being paying
attention to prices,
this is the problem with
food and agriculture
is that people talk
about the three
pillars of sustainability-- or I
would say the three things that
undermine it.
But you have environmental
sustainability here,
you have farmer incomes here,
you have labor issues here,
and you have consumer access
and accessibility here.
These things are
not well aligned.
They are in tension
with each other.
And in my opinion,
the only thing
that can kind of make it all
work out is state involvement.
Because if you have cheaper
prices for consumers,
then you have poorer conditions
and poorer wages for workers.
But none of those things, even
that whatever has happened,
none of those things have
happened without fights--
and that's precisely
the point is consumers
complain in more collectively.
But you know, Trader
Joe's is a tough one.
I mean Taylor Farms is one
of their main suppliers.
I think Trader Joe's--
their supply chain is not one
that we would want to emulate.
There's a reason
the food is really,
really cheap at Trader Joe's.
And the milk they supply comes--
it's organic milk
but it's coming
from farms with huge feed lots.
And that farm,
it's Aurora Dairy--
it's more than one farm.
Aurora Dairy is likely to lose
its organic certification--
so I hear.
Yeah?
- Hi, my name's [INAUDIBLE],,
organizer for Equal Exchange.
I had kind of a related question
about specifically the Whole
Foods-Amazon merger and kind
of that press release that was
them really trying to deal with
food access and making those
products more accessible
to a lower income,
and what your thoughts
and reactions on, one,
that merger and then secondly
that press release that talks
about food access--
specifically in that context.
- Well, that merger
is distressing to me
because, you know, I'm not
a small is better person.
I actually think that
super small businesses
work at some disadvantage.
I think that there's
some ways in which
if we looked at more
mid-scale operations
we could do more of this
collective buying practices.
But any corporation that big,
of Amazon and Whole Foods,
is a really frightening
thought to me.
You know, the accessibility
thing with Whole Foods,
it's another one of these
double-edged swords.
And this goes back to this
other question before--
I once walked into the Whole
Foods in Berkeley, California
and there was a handwritten sign
on the cash register that says,
bring in your
damage canned goods
and we'll give it to the
Alameda County Food Bank.
And I'm like, wait a minute.
So we're shopping here
at Whole Foods and, like,
the poor people get our damage,
non-organic goods at the food--
I mean, there's something
fundamentally wrong with this.
Some of the kind of
food recovery efforts
really disturb me,
because it's, again,
reinforcing that the wealthy and
privilege and the well-located
get the good stuff and everybody
else gets the handouts.
And there's something
fundamentally wrong with that.
So that's my reaction.
- Hi.
My name is [? Leron ?]
[INAUDIBLE]..
And you'll have to excuse
me, I don't normally
fan out about
people, but you were
saying about your
writing has really
informed a lot of
activists and Weighing
In is probably the most
marked book on my bookshelf,
has held dear to me.
And I started
reading this new book
and I do highly recommend it, so
I'll shamelessly plug for you.
- Aw, thank you.
- And one thing that I see in
your writing to some extent,
but I think I'm
still grappling with
and I'm wondering if you
have some ideas about,
is that I think there's also an
element of self gratification
with food activism.
You know, we want to buy a
product and feel good about it
because and that's
something we'll
enjoy but then it's
also something that's
saving the world, or we want
to donate to the food bank
because that's easy and
we can feel good about it.
But it's not that
lasting change.
And I think with a lot
of social movements,
instead of challenges,
you're going
to have to grapple with
questions of white power.
You have to grapple
with your own privilege.
And you have to get out
of that comfort zone
to then go into that
political sphere, which
I think a lot of people
have a hard time doing,
or they find that that
easy answer checks off
enough of that mental
checklist in their brain
that they don't have to move
into that political sphere.
- Yeah, I think it's a
really, really tough question.
And I grapple with it
personally all the time.
I know somebody's going to
ask me if I eat organic food
and buy it-- and somebody will
ask me that, so I'll just say,
yes, I do.
And I just think that, as
I was telling my students,
sometimes you have to
live with contradiction.
But I think that there's
something about the food
movement in particular that--
well, we know what it is about
the food because food is what?
Sustenance.
And food is pleasure.
So there's something
about that food movement
where that contradiction
comes to a head.
I mean, while it may be fun to--
oh, I have I still have Black
Lives Matter on the screen;
you have strawberries.
It may be fun to attend
a rally or a march--
which may or may not be all that
effective, but it may be fun,
but it's not what's
motivating you.
But with food movements
that's what's motivating you,
and I think that's why so
much food movements have
been about teaching people
how to eat because, oh, I
have the pleasures of eating
like Alice Waters of Chez
Panisse tells me to
with my organic kale
with lots of garlic
and salt and olive oil.
So let me teach
you about it, too.
Let me share the
pleasure with you.
And I think that it's
because of the food
itself that kind of
gets the movement
into that very contradictory
place of pleasure and action.
And I don't know that
there's any way around that.
But I do think it's unique.
And I don't know if that
gets to your question, but--
- Good effort.
- OK.
- Hi.
Thank you so much for speaking.
I wanted to pick up
on a point that you'd
made earlier about how
some of your students
have this tendency to want to
go out and teach poor people how
to cook, which might be
well intentioned but sort
of misguided.
And I wanted to get your
thoughts on something,
because I do think that people
of all economic backgrounds
do rely too much on
processed food, fast food,
and it's detrimental
to everyone's health.
I think it can also be
detrimental to our sense
of culture and just general
empowerment in your life.
And I think that
a lot that you can
trace that back to
systemic issues--
we phased out home ec
in schools, for example.
And so I guess
I'm just wondering
if you have thoughts
on how to address sort
of the cooking side
of it from more
of a systemic issue
instead of just these,
let's do little workshops and
teach poor people how to cook.
- Yeah, no, that's another
kind of a biting question here.
I was at a--
I'm sorry.
All these stories keep
popping into my brain.
But I was at this book
fair in Los Angeles
and I was speaking
about my book.
And there was an
author of a cookbook.
She says, if all we need
to do is teach people
how to make vinaigrette.
The cooking thing is an
interesting one, right?
And Michael Pollan
and others have
written about that we
need to get kind of back
to the kitchen.
And I like cooking.
Cooking's a good thing.
But I still think
there's this fun--
why do people not cook?
Maybe they love the
Jack in the Box,
but I mean when you
have people with two
jobs or single parents,
they're picking up their--
I mean, let's get real here
about the cooking thing.
So I think it's nice to cook.
I'd like to-- ultimately I
think people could eat more
nutritiously and
possibly cheaper--
not super cheap with
cooking, but you
have to face the real
obstacles to cooking.
But I think that's
a different issue
than like this kind of
proselytizing about cooking,
and for me that when my
students are picking up
on that is that it's been more
that they can't imagine what
else is possible to
change the food system.
Now they can more,
but that's where
they were about 10
years ago-- well,
what else are we going to do?
I go, well, look, here's
this great organization that
does great anti-pesticide work.
Well, I don't want
to sit behind a desk.
I don't want to
be in a computer.
So sometimes that
pleasure really can--
excuse me.
Something that
pleasure can really
get in the way of
what's important.
I mean, if we think of other
kind of important moments
of our time--
important activism,
you wouldn't--
I'm just trying to think of
some analogous situation.
If you were concerned about
Syrian refugees, for example,
you wouldn't--
I can't think of the analogous
situation where we'd say, well,
I want to do this
because it's more fun.
So, again, there's something
about the food movement
that puts us in that, well,
I want to just have fun
while I'm doing this.
- Hi.
My name's Rachel and I'm
a student at the School
of Public Health here.
And I had a question on--
you described the current
pessimistic political climate
and also a lot about
what bothers you what
people do around food activism.
But, under the
assumption that everybody
here is interested
in food activism
and wants to take
action, what do
you recommend as next steps
for when we leave this room?
Like, is there
anything concrete you
can think of to do in our daily
lives that would really help?
- Well, you know there are--
not many-- but there
are good organizations
that do good work, organizations
that do pesticide activism.
Some Some of them have
letter writing campaigns.
You can join one of those
and get on their ListServes.
It's always better to
write individual notes
than just do the
clicktivism, but, you know.
Like, for instance, right
now Pesticide Action Network
is working hard to put that
chlorpyrifos ban back in place.
So you have to get
on the ListServes.
You have to write letters.
But it worked on this
methyl iodide campaign.
So that's one place you can go.
The Farm Bill should
be coming up soon,
and I expect to see the
Trump Administration come up
with a really nasty one.
And there will be
many organizations
that will be working on that.
So whether you only
can write your letter--
but an individualized letter--
or give $100, that's something.
Or if you're a
student and you're
looking to employ
yourself later,
you can intern and
get involved and work.
But those things do exist.
Or working on--
there's so many--
how you work on immigration
reform is a tough one, right?
I mean, whether you're
immigration reform
or immigration, whether
you're like leaving
plastic jugs of water in the
desert in Arizona or, again,
lobbying your congressperson
about a safer,
better immigration bill,
those are different options.
But there's lots.
But they're not always
as tangibly about food,
and I think that's
one of the things,
too, is that the policies that
I think impinge on the food
system are not always
about that material thing
called food-- they're about
the systems that are around it.
- Hi-- oh, sorry.
I'm [? Nicole ?] [INAUDIBLE].
I'm a Harvard Extension
Sustainability Master's
student, and my question, or
two of our biggest global issues
is soil security and soil
fertility, as well as the food
waste that we throw away.
So in developed countries we're
sending about 40% to landfill.
So my question is, is
there or should there
be discussions
around a to cradle
to grave initiative for
the agriculture sector,
and does this present
any opportunities
to resolve any of the
issues that you've
discussed with us today?
- Food waste is a tricky one.
I think food waste is a
huge aesthetic problem--
no one likes to see food waste.
Most of the food waste--
and this isn't answering
your question directly,
it's just what I know about--
most of the food
waste initiatives
are really geared
toward consumers,
like, here's how to
reuse that or use
that kale that's been
sitting there in your door
for three weeks.
Most of the food waste occurs
in agricultural production--
and lots of it.
And it's-- yes, there are
organizations that do food
recovery, whether it's
organizing gleaning.
But our food production system
is geared to create food waste.
It's profitable to
create food waste.
So, again, it's a matter
of figure out ways
to address how food is
produced through policy
and through somehow changing
up the incentives so
corporate farming--
it's not only
individual farmers
just don't leave
so much food on the field.
But, you know,
your question also
brings us to bigger
questions about,
what is the nature of hunger?
And if it's about
insufficient food production.
I'm concerned about food
waste because you don't
want to see soil go to waste.
You don't want to see animal
lives put down for nothing.
But I'm always worried
about food recovery
as a way to address it.
And that's about as much as
I can say about at this point
because it's not something
I've looked at a lot.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Thank you, Julie.
That was fantastic.
Join me in congratulating her
for a stimulating lecture.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]